the symbol for the Higgs boson is sadly
the most boring thing in the world it's
a lowercase letter H it is it depends
you know different there's no
agreed-upon symbol I think the lowercase
H is the most common but uppercase H is
used uppercase Phi or lowercase Phi or
various other things are sometimes used
the Higgs boson is a tiny little
vibration in a field called the Higgs
field just as the photon the particle of
light is a tiny vibration in the
electromagnetic field for example the
Higgs boson is not important the Higgs
boson is a little bit of a red herring
what matters what is crucial for the
operation of physics is the Higgs field
that pervades all of space and the
reason why we've spent so much effort
looking for the Higgs boson is because
it's evidence that there is something
called the Higgs field it's a vibration
in this field that we've been looking
for for over 40 years now is the Higgs
boson the only way to find the Higgs
field well it's the direct way
so when Steven Weinberg and Selam put
together what we call the electroweak
theory when they unified
electromagnetism with the weak nuclear
force they assumed that the universe was
full of this thing called the Higgs
field and have played a crucial role in
making sense of the rest of the physics
that followed and that theory made
predictions and it fit a lot of data and
the predictions came true Nobel Prizes
were given to Glashow Weinberg Salaam to
a Tufton Veltman for figuring out the
mathematical underpinnings of the theory
for the experimenters carla rubia and
simon van der Meer for finding the W and
Z bosons that were predicted but it was
relying on this ingredient the Higgs
field that had never been directly
detected the LHC is an amazing amazing
piece of equipment I mean I wrote this
book about the search for the Higgs and
I came to it as a theoretical
cosmologist I was already very very
impressed with the experimenters before
I started writing the book but I'm much
more impressed now having done it the
largest machine ever built
thousands of people working on it 27
kilometers around thousands of
superconducting magnets colder than
interstellar space a vacuum inside the
bean pipe
that is emptier than the atmosphere of
the moon and they're colliding particles
together protons together at incredibly
high energies and just watching what
comes out and the amazing single most
amazing fact to me about the LHC is that
when you collide protons together we
have such a wonderful understanding of
particle physics that almost everything
that comes out is exactly what you would
expect so what they do is they just over
produce data you know they have a
hundred million collisions per second
very very roughly the problem with that
is that every collision is a megabyte of
data and there's no possible way you can
store all that information so for every
million events that they produce they
store one of them to tape they very
quickly look at the event say is this
possibly interesting oh no they throw it
away or yes and they will keep it so
this idea of filtering and throwing away
almost all the data turns out to be
necessary because what you're looking
for is you know the one in a hundred
billion event you can't do it just by
creating less data and keeping it all
right you need to go through this
elaborate process and miraculously you
know there was one thing we thought that
was absolutely going to be found at the
LHC and we found it and that's the Higgs
boson we're still looking for things
beyond that of course but what is it
about what the Large Hadron Collider
does that produces that one in a billion
event well if you believe as I do that
we should think about particle physics
in terms of fields what's really
happening is that the inner workings of
the protons are quarks and gluons
so there's vibrating quark fields and
vibrating gluon fields and they smack
together and create a very elaborate
high amplitude vibration so it's much
like if you're playing the piano very
loudly in one room there's another piano
sitting the room next to you it will
begin to hum along in resonance with
your sound waves so these gluons and
quarks start vibrating and they start
the other fields of particle physics -
vibrating because all the fields are
coupled to each other in very subtle
ways so gluons start vibrating and then
top quarks start vibrating and
ultimately a Higgs vibration is brought
into existence and it decays almost
instantly in about one Zepto
second so you will never see the Higgs
boson in any experiment ever done it
instantly turns into other things and
then the hard work begins because you
need to pick out the Higgs events the
the collisions where Higgs boson was
produced by looking at all the different
events you got and say well there's more
of this type of event that we would have
expected so you do a little bit of
detective work and say the only way that
could be true is if there's a Higgs when
these huge collisions happen with all
this energy and all these fields start
wiggling why is the higgs field so
reluctant to join the party there's
there's two reasons the most simple
reason is that it's heavy a heavy field
is one that has a lot of mass and as we
all know e equals MC squared so energy
of a particle just sitting there is the
mass times the speed of light squared so
creating a particle with a lot of mass
means you need to take a lot of energy
and put into a very very small region of
space that's why you need this elaborate
9 billion-dollar particle accelerator
just to make a few tiny Higgs bosons and
the other thing besides the energy that
it takes is how it couples how it
interacts with other fields the top
court for example is a little bit
heavier than the Higgs boson but it's a
little bit easier to make because it
interacts more directly with other
fields that we know about so in particle
physics you just can characterize
everything you're looking for by how
heavy it is and how it interacts how you
can make it and the Higgs was right
there where the LHC could finally find
it Higgs bosons do form very very very
rarely but it does happen because you
have to remember everything that the
Large Hadron Collider does the universe
does all the time and better there are
cosmic rays that are impacting the
Earth's atmosphere with much higher
energies than we can produce at the LHC
but they're up high in the Earth's
atmosphere then the Higgs boson decays
one Zepto second later so it's kind of
Impractical to search for new exotic
particles that way but definitely a
Higgs fields are vibrating throughout
the universe there is the the non
vibrating field you know the background
and that is crucially important to all
the particle physics electrons and
quarks and so forth move through this
Higgs like molasses or I should say
Blass is like Higgs and that's how they
get mass that
so it makes the universe interesting you
know there's only a small number of
fundamental ingredients of reality I
mean in fact you could bring it down you
could boil it down to four if you wanted
to there's gravity there are the other
forces of nature all of which sort of
have the same kind of basic structure
there is the matter particles that make
up your atoms you know the the up and
down quarks and your protons and
neutrons the electrons in your atoms and
then there's the Higgs right so it's one
of a very very tiny number of
fundamental ingredients you need to
explain the world around you how much is
it worth finding that and verifying that
it's there the only accurate answer is
that it's priceless right you know it
depends on how much money you have to
spend on basic research because you're
not trying to cure cancer with this
you're not trying to fly to Mars or
anything like that we're not going to
get jetpacks it's not going to make a
better iphone but it helps us understand
how the world works I mean it's a
feature of doing this kind of research
that you always do get technological
spin-offs the world wide web was a
spinoff of research at CERN but that's
not why we do it we do it because we
want to understand things and
fortunately we still have enough money
to do it I guess I mean I'm not asking
for a jetpack or even a cure to cancer
but has this unlocked a new level has
this unlocked for you guys has unlocked
a new level or is it just is it leur is
it the URI well done pat on the back
now we're certainly very hopeful that it
is not only a capstone achievement but a
window onto a whole new world one of the
nice things about the Higgs boson is
that it's a little bit more sociable
than other kinds of particles and we
know there are particles we haven't yet
detected we know there's dark matter in
the universe if it weren't for dark
matter and dark energy we might really
be worried that the particles we already
knew about we're all that we're
accessible to us but we know that's not
true they're the most of the of the mass
in our galaxy is not made of particles
that we've created here on earth so
we're hopeful that by studying the Higgs
boson this gives us a new way of looking
for other particles the ways that the
Higgs boson is produced the way it
decays the way it uses it becomes a
force mediating interactions between
dark matter particles and other
particles these are all new toys for
particle physics to study and play with
this is going to be going on for twenty
thirty forty years into the future these
are some incredibly talented
hard-working dedicated bright human
beings the theorists the technicians and
the experimenters who built the theories
and built the Large Hadron Collider and
they've devoted their lives literally to
looking for a particle that may or may
not be there and that when you find it
is not going to make you any richer it's
just going to make you a little bit
happier that you found it
so I wanted to get across why this was
so crucial I mean why physicist in the
United States were crushed with
disappointment when Congress in 1993
cancelled the United States is
competitor to the Large Hadron Collider
the superconducting supercollider why
physicists are still a little bit on
tenterhooks about will there ever be
another particle accelerator the scale
of the LHC you know they devote their
lives to it the theorists might spend
their entire life working on a theory
that the accelerator then says isn't
true you know you have to learn to deal
with that but you then get these
pictures of Peter Higgs and and and
Francois layer and other physicists who
came up with the idea of the Higgs boson
back in 1964 and they got to be in the
room in 2012 when the experimenters told
them you are right that is part of
nature and that is a kind of sweet
triumphant success that we can rarely
experience as human beings for me
really an incredible singing that has
happened in my lifetime as a
cosmetologist who's alive at this time
you're very fortunate you got to enjoy
this announcement you won't live forever
I'm sure does it frustrate you that
those next things those things that are
40 50 60 years away just beyond your
lifetime you'll never get to see do you
ever think about that well I think that
the great thing about science is that we
almost are always focused on what we
don't yet understand and sometimes the
new understandings come fast and furious
you know there are times like the 1920s
when quantum mechanics was being put
together when it's hard to imagine what
it must have been like when I wrote my
book about the arrow of time I delved
into the work in statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics in the 1870s and the
debates there are just fascinating to
read because they didn't know it was
really fundamental stuff and they were
building it from scratch and some people
didn't believe in atoms at all right and
other people were using atoms to explain
everything and now in particle physics
we put the capstone on the standard
model and we're hoping to find dark
matter in cosmology we found dark matter
and dark energy I can't say over the
next 10 years 50 years are we going to
be strewn with new shocking experimental
results or are we just going to be you
know fine-tuning the understanding we
already have I think the fact that we
don't know which of those is going to
happen is part of what actually makes it
interesting but I think about someone
that Albert Einstein when he was born
and I kind of think oh gee I wish I
could just tell those guys what we found
out a few weeks ago they would have been
so happy to know better and it'll be the
same for you when you were gone I wish I
could have told Sean about this thing he
would have loved to know that does that
does that eat away it does it does not
actually because you could say about
anybody right you could say the a what
would I 9 have told Newton but you know
Newton had his own fun right he got to
invent physics basically right I mean
Newton could have told Galileo things
but Galileo did his own his own thing I
think that every generation gets to
apply the talents it has to the problems
that it's faced with and right now in
science not just particle physics and
cosmology but overall there's so many
great problems and so much interesting
data coming in
and that we are at no loss for
interesting questions to puzzle over the
change of the evolution of the universe
we only need one we only need the
trigger equation it in the Copenhagen
interpretation the the thing that we
teach our students the thing that's in
the textbooks